[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing the upcoming and newly titled
fantastic beasts film fantastic beasts
the secrets of dumbledore i'm coming to
you all with news about the film and i
can't say that it's good because you see
it appears as if a rather major
character may have been taken out of the
film series with the first installment
fantastic beasts and where to find them
being released in 2016 and the second
installment fantastic beasts the crimes
of grindelwald being released in 2018
we've had a serious shortage of
fantastic beasts content as of late
which is why the news that the third
film dropping in april of 2022 at least
in north america is very welcome while
still very much within the same
wizarding world as harry potter the
fantastic beasts films differ in that
they follow many different new
characters some of which are alluded to
in the harry potter books and films
however one of the big differences in
the second film from the first that i
noticed was that more old characters had
been reintroduced dumbledore mcgonagall
if it is indeed the same mcgonagall and
the character that this video focuses on
this video may contain a small spoiler
for the film but i will say that this
information is not 100 confirmed so you
may be safe regardless now with the film
being released fairly soon in north
america it should be safe to assume that
filming and production is entirely
complete this means that no more
characters can be added no more scenes
shot it also means the final product
that a select lucky few have already
witnessed throughout the globe may
actually omit a character that we know
from both film franchises nakini now let
me start off by saying that this isn't
confirmed information this is hearsay
from people who have purportedly already
watched a screening of the film it
popped up in my news feed and when i did
some digging i was able to find a few
more sources indicating the same thing
this news would also line up with the
fact that actress claudia kim has not
been confirmed to be reprising her role
and it also lines up with the fact that
neither the film nor kim's imdb profiles
have any indication of her playing
nagini kim has only been in one film so
far the second and she's already had
quite a big impact on the story getting
close with credence who is central to
the story so i wonder what's going on
here we know that later on once the
harry potter stories timeline sets in
that nagini becomes a prevalent
character voldemort's trusty serpentine
companion she becomes entirely
instrumental in voldemort's return to
power and her venom is even used in an
elixir that allows him to rebuild his
strength but when the crimes of
grindelwald ended nakini wasn't trapped
as a snake the result of her maledictus
curse she was still able to transform
into a woman she also didn't appear to
be evil in any way crimes of grindelwald
made me feel bad for nagini so when did
she turn bad there's clearly a lot of
her story still to tell and i for one am
curious as to what happens to her in
this void between 1927 when she's last
seen in crimes of grindelwald and 1994
when she reappears
there are also supposed to be five
fantastic beast films in total spanning
1926-1945
but again this hasn't been confirmed
either what do you guys think has nagini
been scrapped i think she's a great
character and removing her would do the
franchise a great injustice she doesn't
appear in secrets of dumbledore i hope
she at least shows up in the next films
comment down below any information or
theories you have about the new
fantastic beasts film also please
remember to like the video and subscribe
to the channel until next time
remember we want only freedom freedom to
be ourselves the disapproval of cowards
is praise to the brave
[Music]
you